all right so this is what was missing
I'm just gonna talk about what we were
talking about before the V log started
uh what's going on with Marceline and uh
bubble gum that cuz you were just like
you know I did maybe something
completely was had going oh hey you
sound not to give away cos eternally put
no you say you know say think it's good
boy everything but just tell no no no
he's also angry you and the Florence I
just want to see you talk about it
everyone it for me for a minute
it's nothing to be ruined it's just when
Bree first started showing me this show
and everything this was already you know
does show kept moving along and I wasn't
really keeping up and I heard about this
episode and there's a lot of controversy
over it really because there were groups
that were bitching and moaning because
bubblegum and Marceline this episode
shows them quote-unquote having a past
homosexual relationship well with the
shirt with the shirt the way that
Marceline is singing to bubblegum the
way they're reacting to each other
they're supposedly a lot of you know gay
undertones to it and people were
flipping the hell out over it you know
it and I never I was excited to see the
episode the first time and I watched it
I'm like I guess if you really dig sure
you can find it but that was just kind
of cute you know for a show that I mean
look over the set up real fast here the
was it the Tour Masters that was called
or the doors that was it thank you
floating bodies magic voice I'll call
you the door Lord comes it just
hilarious open because it just closed
and I love that this Oh his face was
brilliant and wholesome he's just like
pops up and it pops up so quick makes
these weird sounds sound who's so quick
throws a door steal something of theirs
that runs into the door goes to another
place they're trying to follow it and
goes best this kid steals the toy he
gets the neighborhood Kato manicured
don't worry joy I'll get you back
kid I mean it's like it's going so fast
even Finn can't keep the words together
because everything is happening so fast
and it's a perfect opening because the
rest of it is so is so much slower and
calmer and more subdue with so it's a
perfect freaking hilarious opening and
the design of this thing the way it
talks it doesn't tell you just goes like
that it has like extra length arms with
like an extra elbow and stuff and it's
just a great design it's so funny
but then they get to this door and it
has this little riddle that pretty much
says you have to sing in a band to open
it and they're trying to figure it so
they're trying to do that it's it's
Bubblegum's Marceline
it's a Finn and Jake and beemo ten beemo
that's right and I think and so they're
trying to do these various songs to try
and open it up and sometimes it's
working sometimes it's not and they're
trying to figure out how and why and I'm
just gonna say now because we're talking
about cosplays a lot in the last one
Jake as the jerk rocker they say what
cosplay does that cuz they ever seen
that that is how we're like if I cosplay
- I would do that I would put like all I
am for whatever instance somehow making
that Jake
jerk rock and whether you just showed up
with the book Darrin just the notes
about the music every time he was on
screen he looks like that it killed me
I'm sad when he's running away just like
I quit the bed I'm just good yeah and
the baby runs away back baby that's
obvious just for attention whatever but
all right so will you forgot what's the
door Lord doing he's stealing something
important to everyone yeah and that
brings them together and they eventually
find out that to sing about the truth
and that opens up the door and they say
oh it was all about bringing us together
wasn't the door Lord so happy then you
can take him just beaten to a pulp and
at the end everyone's given something
back and Bubblegum's give him back this
rocker shirt which interest they think
it's Marceline yeah they think us
marcelina then it's revealed that
Marceline Angele
that to her and that bubblegum actually
it meant a lot to her and Marceline kind
of didn't know and then Marceline at you
didn't lose anything she just wanted to
hang out and then she gets really angry
and chases omits you know it's nice and
anything you can get as a girl turn into
a giant monster chasing them can be so
okay so the whole episode like I said is
it with the exception of the opening and
evil can the ending is very slow and
very sorry character developing and it
has a lot of music to it which is really
nice and it turns out what's missing to
open the door is truth and the two big
elements that start to open it one is
Marceline snapping at bubblegum and
which is not usually that big a shock
whatever but it's like this really long
song sequence I mean she's really going
into details sort of like with the whole
the dad and the fries thing mm-hmm and
that starts to open it up but then she
can't keep it going or she can't think
we're extend the door closes and then
Finn realizes when he starts singing
about it how he feels about bubblegum
and what was taken for him and stuff
that starts open up and realizes it was
the truth and they start to sing and
that opens up um the the the first thing
I'll talk about before we get to the
Marceline bubblegum thing is the UH I I
really like the kid doing Finn when he
starts singing in kind that I think it's
kind of full set oh don't you know quote
me on that but I think it is yes so the
videos like that and say he pulls that
off really well because it was it
sounded like there's a lot of motion in
that number right the kid who Dustin is
an actual singer yeah I mean he yeah and
he did that it sounded very authentic I
mean for someone that because usually in
musicals especially in animation I mean
the voice has it sound really good or
it's people struggling to make it sound
really good that was a very emotional
tone that Betty hit and people forget
that can work just as well
it's a nice sounding voice to it don't
get me wrong but I thought that was a
real real good note that he hit no pun
intended and then uh
there's this whole thing with Marceline
bubblegum and I like when he's singing
about we realizes the true of these
things about how much they all mean to
them and stuff I like what he says I
even liked when you two fought yeah I
like that because it's still saying look
yeah that it sucks that we had to fight
but at the same time it's nice that we
care about each other enough that we can
fight it's nice that we care about
enough that we can open up to kind of
fight yeah and we can show you know what
makes us angry and we can we can be this
way we're comfortable enough to be this
way around each other so I like that
it's just like one lyric but I actually
did kind of strike a chord again no pun
intended with me is so it's honestly for
me that was probably the biggest moment
where I was just like what like that was
nice that was a like the tone and
everything hell with the but I really
like that one lyric but yeah okay so
let's talk about this whole possible
lesbian
Marceline bubblegum thing is it ever
when I'm going too much detail has it
ever kind of addressed again or hinted
at again um when I said I won't say it's
addressed it's never in any way shape or
form actually fully addressed - guess a
they would never say it out loud at
least now despite um but there's a few
of the things that do kind of come up
that I don't know if they're trying to
say that yes this actually happened no
it didn't or what or if they're just
kind of messing with people but a few
things do kind of pop up here and there
and there's some stuff that's actually
kind of touching that does happen later
on it's it's interesting because
watching it I did think it was a little
weird that particularly when Marceline
was singing so long mm-hmm uh in the
beginning with the door and I was like
wow she's like really obsessing over
this but then again she also got really
upset when her dad ate her fries and I
don't know how that all ties in
necessarily if it does that's all part
of a joke whatever so you look like you
have something interest actually um I do
peek on the forums and all that stuff
and I don't know a few people have said
it and I think they may have actually
hit the nail on the head with the hole
fry song I think they may have gotten it
because I think we're looking a bit too
deep
to it they brought up the fact that one
it's after the apocalypse food is scarce
- so the fact that she had food and her
father who doesn't even need food to
survive or even do anything as eating
the fries just cuz he kind of can but I
said it's one of those things where it's
like she's like you took one thing that
was kind of actually important to me and
you don't even need it it's like taking
away kid's toy and tossing it to the
side just because I was gonna say you
know what I can see I can I can see it
being something like you said that
represents that they it really means a
lot to her because it's like the one
thing possibly from the past world or
whatever pocalypse how is it easy as it
gonna be to get fries I I don't know if
I guess but I don't know aren't there
like food people and stymie holidays and
isn't she a vampire now so she like eats
other people or hi for how to she can
drink blood but she likes you know the
color I'm so likes to eat red only
that's like she likes to eat red that's
right so I mean would that even matter I
at the same time she's still a person or
a female or a kid hmm you know you you
have to think about it from that
perspective of dad is doing something
just because he can and without regard
for how she even feels maybe I mean I
don't know did you come very well be I
don't know but whoever said that on the
forums I agree with them it was it's an
interesting thought I'm not disagreeing
I know I'm saying it's interesting which
is a very nice way of saying I disagree
no but uh it could be bubble lean thing
as people call it anger sounds like a
detergent is something that definitely
floats around in the fanfic and all of
that for this episode I'm sure yeah it's
you know what I was saying is that I
didn't think that much about it cuz I'm
a vet your time weird they and they get
upset or happy about the strangest
things uh but now
that's what put out there it's like
impossible for me not to see it
mmm uh the other thing it would really
explain is why bubblegum is not that
interested in defend women you know I
mean she's she's getting older and you
know she's has interests elsewhere and
it's like not only here here's this kid
that's like younger than her but at the
same time it's just yeah that's what she
likes so yeah then now now that's put
out there I think is interesting but
even if you took that element of it
let's say that's not a that's just like
a really close friendship it would be
interesting if there's definitely
something that marcelina bubblegum had
that you didn't see before and you
weren't even really made aware of that
there was sort of there was definitely
like this pass whether it be a
friendship or relationship whatever um
that was never hinted at before and if
they touch on it more and more I would
like to see that because I'm just
curious it doesn't even matter that much
to me I mean it would be nice to know
but it doesn't matter that much if they
were just friends or their actual item
suggests you'd like to know I'd like to
know what I'd like to know what they
shared I'd like to know exactly like
what they connected on because they seem
like two very different people and it's
nice to see how they would come together
at something or even like what set them
apart so I don't see now it's like
whether it's a friendship or or like I
said they were a couple about like
friggin fascinated I don't know if it
necessarily would have caught on to that
I mean I definitely would have gotten
like the shirt meant something hmm you
know and you think that the Marceline
actually blushes over it and everything
yeah but that's when Adventure Time does
really well it starts out as this cutesy
weird bizarre kids show but as it goes
along it's like holy crap these
characters have a bit more behind them
I'd like to know more and they throw in
an episode where you learn a little bit
but not so much where it's like oh you
don't need to know any more about
bubblegum or Marceline or anything
you get bits and pieces that make you
want to keep watching to see the whole
thing finally unfold you know that
reminds me of it reminds me kind of like
what Family Guy
I could have been or was almost going in
one direction where it's like we start
off in a world where we can do anything
yeah it's like wow the possibilities and
for a while they do sort of do that
but then they just sort of a family guy
had very little I mean if there was
character but not a ton to go off on so
we're I think they need to create more
characters sometimes they did it went
more if we're kind of just the weird
joke after we're joggin starts to get
predictable and I have a watch in a
while uh but with this show it takes the
event it seems to take every advantage
that it has with this idea that it can
take something where anything can happen
and it can throw anything you want into
it so if you're in a certain mood or
you're in a you had this idea that you
want to express her you have a new
character you can just do it and
nobody's gonna question it or get angry
anything cuz it's just that kind of
world it created and it keeps you sucked
in because there's still this core focus
on these very likeable characters that
you learn more and more about and this
world that keeps throwing new things at
you I mean I never bored with this world
and that's really shocking for something
that's so supposed to be so unexpected
and constantly be throwing fresh to new
things which is really harder than it
sounds
but they they really do such a good job
it reminds me of or makes me think of I
don't know when it's called the
executive balls that's what I call them
don't worry you have two three balls and
there's the four and five in you hit the
three balls in the center are the
average episodes the two on the end that
swing vastly further out you have the
overly bizarre comedic ones and then in
between that you have a few normal ones
and then you have the overly emotional
ones where you actually learn or you
gain respect for characters and most
shows don't have a balance of that where
or they do they stick out like a sore
thumb yeah this one it's like a natural
reaction going back and forth between
the
to where you're right they can throw
whatever at you and you can take it in
stride because you're used to this
normal momentum that the show is created
and I think part of that to that I think
a lot of good shows have figured out is
that it's not as much adding new stuff
on top of what you already know it's
finding out what you didn't know about
them before like this I mean this
episode is just getting back a shirred
and some errands it's getting back these
little items but it's finding out more
about the past history and you know so
much of the past is a mystery and I
think you find out more about the
characters through what they have been
shown that you lost it that alone I
think very effectively a little avatar
my friend there did that a lot so yeah
it's it's a good way doing it's a
tougher more complicated way but I think
it pays off you've done well and I think
this is done well it doesn't sit there
and throw something in your face and go
see look at what happens back then look
at what happened back then it's like oh
look something may have happened yeah
you want to work for it a little watch
where you can't enjoy the show even if
you don't want to work for it like you
can watch this brain-dead not care and
just want to laugh you can still enjoy
it fine but if you want to read more
into it if you want know more about the
characters and the end this past reason
hook go to the library that too the more
you know it'll be interesting to see if
I actually am not lazy enough to put
that little caption Internet oh please
do I want to but like I said my memory
and my laziness might get in the way so
don't lose it you'll just have to stay -
yeah nice so I quit to be logs I'm not
here man I was gonna lose this one
anyway